hey what's up guys welcome back to my
channel hey guys
amanda here i'm back amanda my wife you
came on the show last week and actually
it was actually
not like i was super surprised but it
was a hit i know yeah there's lots and
lots of really good feedback thank you
so much for the lovely comments
and i think what people are really
interested in is i think they're
interested
in um i think people just knows it
some people just like to know what we
get up to in our spare time
so this week i wanted to talk about cars
okay i talk about property a lot but
cars um holidays
yes lock down okay plans
yep but before we go into that what
you've been up to this week
what have i been up to so i'm sure lots
of you have seen
that it was samuel's 30th birthday it
was it was a good day
yep and we were in the lockdown so i
planned
something really special for you and he
didn't know anything about it so
samuel loves experiences he loves
dinners
and socializing with people that he
loves so i arranged an
intimate um dinner party we had a chef
come
cook us a three-course meal it was
really good yeah it was really really
nice and we also had the room all
decorated nice
something as well though that samuel
loves is like shisha
which we usually do when we go on
holidays abroad and we haven't been
away for well the past year so um so i
got someone to come and set up some
seashell outside we had a fire pit it
was just so nice it was
so you didn't know anything about it
until the actual
the day off the night off when it was
all about i just said to you
we need to you need to dress up at this
time and then yeah
you know that was that was it the only
problem with it was that
i could probably get used to the idea of
having a chef every night
oh i know he was like hmm we could have
this every week it wasn't that expensive
he was like this is about as expensive
as just going out for a meal yeah so
65 pounds ahead yeah with a three-course
meal lambshank
everything yeah great so so yeah that
was really good
um i do think we could probably have a
chef more often um it was nice
holidays are nice you also booked me a
paragliding trip which oh yeah
i had to cancel because the weather was
a bit a bit too yeah the weather wasn't
fearful for it
um so okay because because anyone
doesn't know me super well
um might not know the thing i like to
spend my money on is
experiences experiences like i'm very
happy to spend my own experiences
don't like spending money on clothes so
much don't like spending money on like
objects things that are plastic or just
things stuff
um but i do like spending money on
experiences so holidays i mean we've
spent so
much money on hotels yeah and holidays
yeah
um that's great well what i've been up
to well
eating great food and being spoiled by
amanda from my 30th also writing the
book
the success students book which actually
is a really good book isn't it
it is a really really good book i just
love that there's so many different
people in the book
and lots of different people can relate
to you know the different people that
are in there but
just the success stories we didn't you
know you haven't read it already
you can get it on amazon but it's
basically 30 chapters because i turn 30
and every chapter is dedicated to one of
my success students
and it's really inspirational it's a
beautiful read
um so i've been publishing that i've
been promoting that i've been looking at
new sites
development opportunities um but
what i wanted to talk about is cars okay
because
cars we're upgrading and changing and
stuff cars at the moment
and there's this whole thing about
electric versus
petrol or diesel so we decided which is
quite a big deal
to go electric on our cars i say cars i
should probably say car car
you're the guinea pig right i know i'm
the guest she's the guinea pig
so talk to me about cars talk to me
about electric
versus diesel or petrol and what car
you're looking at
okay so we're looking well yeah so i'm
going to be changing my car soon
i'm not sure which one you're viewing a
lot yeah so i've been viewing lots of
different options of electric cars that
are available
um and i've seen a few different ones
and but the pros of having an electric
car is that it's obviously really good
for the environment
there's tax benefits as well are you
still really good for the environment
yeah there's no no emissions zero
emissions so
i think you know the exhaust pipe it
usually gives off like bad
gases and stuff into the air with
electric cars there's none of that
there's some people that argue electric
has other bad problems like the
radiation problems and
i mean i don't know i haven't really
looked into that so i don't really know
but do you think that's the true reason
why you're wanting to get electric
because you want to help the environment
or is it because of the tax
segments it's probably the taxes
i think it's a bit of birth because i do
care but i mean it's not very i care
about the planet yeah
yeah we should look after it we should
and i think there's nothing there's
nothing worse than people that just
treat
you know you see people just like dump
stuff on the phone oh i really hate it
when people just like chuck glitter on
something so
when it's plastic they treat the earth
like their giant trash can
yeah and it's really really not cool but
there's other things it's really hard to
know there's so many people debating
different things like a plane for
instance you know
the amount of oh yes the toxins
go from a plane it's like should we just
not fly then or we haven't flown for a
long time but it's not really because of
that
i know um but some people say a bit off
topic but
last lockdown you know when we had the
really really good weather last summer
some people were saying it's because
there's less people traveling
because everyone was locked down in
march that um
that because of that it just made the
air clearer and stuff because there
wasn't so much pollutants coming from
the cars
that's just something that i heard but i
don't i don't know how true it is was
that how did you have was it dave
who's dear dave down the pub
[Laughter]
he drove down the pub yeah i'm not so i
don't know if it's a credible thing
comment below is that true or is it not
come on
come on google researchers maybe maybe
he's true
yeah maybe dave was right yeah so yeah
so the main reason is not because
it's not it's only it's not only about
you know here's the thing who's thinking
about electric cars
yeah okay you can claim
100 of
the cost of the car back as tax
deductible
that is huge that is a big big deal not
only
can you claim back 100 of the car itself
but you can claim back the insurance
costs and believe me when you've got as
many points as amanda's got that's huge
i do not have points i mean i just add
i'm such a good girl you know you've
crashed as many times
as crashed you've got a squeaky i've got
a clean license
no bumps the funny thing is though like
me amanda
russell my brother and his wife anna um
we all together we have like a joint
business insurance
and collectively as a four we are
so expensive there are so many points
and stuff on there but to be fair
um you are the cleanest of all i am i'm
the cleanest i'm probably helping
balance it out yeah she balances
massively
i had a driving ban didn't i yeah so my
my insurance is really
and i drive and also yeah yeah you you
don't drive badly though so don't get
the wrong
idea when you were done you i don't
think three times
it was because this one before four
times he was literally going like three
miles over
the speed limit correct so it's not like
he drives reckless
no it was the tottenham i got yeah i do
a lot of driving yeah yeah and
you know listen i don't speed fast i'm
not reckless i'm a safe good driver yeah
um uh but i got caught speeding
just and every time it was just like
three or four miles over it was
really annoying it's quite unfortunate
hidden cameras or whatever
and over fight and it was like just
before the five year period
yeah um that then i got another another
three points but i'm back driving now
again
um but my car is really expensive this
is a big expensive car
and my insurance is really how i pay per
year just myself it's
6 000 pounds a year
for just for me to drive my car on
insurance alone
really really crazy so um yeah so you
can claim the whole car back as tax
deductible the insurance and
there's no diesel or petrol costs nope
which is so good
from it from a commercial point of view
it just is a complete no-brainer
yeah the question is what will it be
like driving an electric car
and how would it work and stuff which is
why i have a fantastic guinea pig
i know i did test drive an electric car
um
and it accelerates really really fast i
was shocked
and it literally feels like it gliding
it just floats well russell russell just
dropped the electric car
i don't know i say i think he's leasing
excellent
we tend to lease our cars yeah my my
range rover i actually own that but
why did i buy my reindeer over and why
did we not miss it i think it was
because
you just loved it and you knew that you
weren't going to get sick of it
that's it that's that's what i'm saying
normally normally i don't want to buy a
car because i usually within 12 months
i'm bored of a car
like after 12 months and after two years
i'm just so
done with it i want to get to it now so
to buy a car it's just stupid especially
if you also i like
brand new cars yeah nice new smell to
buy a brand new car and then sell it a
year later it's just commercially
moronic so you're better off just leaves
yeah
nice new cars and then change them yeah
whenever you want to change them like
how we change our phones
do we own our phones i don't think so no
no we don't we just get them on
contracts i'm on contracts
i've got a neatly fact my new phone was
supposed to come today
amanda ordered it but it just didn't
come yeah
because i said we rang you
the security team rang you to check that
it was you that ordered it and you
didn't answer i'm like
samuel hasn't taken scheduled calls so
if my phone rings i don't know if you
have a ring don't be offended if he
doesn't answer it's because unless it's
scheduled and
it's in his diary he's not gonna answer
exactly i'm not gonna come out of the
meeting
oh sorry hold on someone's calling me i
don't know who it is but i'm gonna sit
like no
you want you want to speak to your book
appointment
i guess you're quite busy right so so so
you're on my income
so now we're gonna have to do a trip to
the three store and get it in person
uh anyway where were we um cars so yeah
pros and cons
so yeah so the the major pro is that
yeah it's tax
deductible so that's good yeah um
nice really really nice it felt so small
getting in it though
it's quite low isn't it actually i
so i'm looking at the mercedes eqc i've
actually done a video about it on my
youtube channel so you can check that
out if you're interested i hope you're
not
just in case you're interested you're
pitching my audience to go and subscribe
you're trying to steal my subscribers
right now
i am yeah go subscribe to me no what
what is this
what is this yeah if you if you want to
see
you know if you want to just see like
you know little lifey vloggy type
no real content no value
then yeah go and subscribe to amanda's
channel if you want to see value
tips and you want to become financially
free stay subscribed to my channel
or you can subscribe to birth yeah
anyway yeah we'll put a link maybe below
thank you but you you edit these anyway
yes i do amanda's in control he's gonna
make the cut
okay so you're gonna get a new card
maybe the mercedes yes
yeah so i'm just looking at different
options i'm trying to get to buy tesla
but
yeah i'm not into tesla's i just feel
i don't know i'm just not into them i
feel like they're a bit too simple
that's that simple yeah it's not really
my vibe
minimalistic simple is great just like
you
i am not simple no you're not simple
you're very very complex thank you
not complex in a bad way
anyway yeah um simple is that an insight
because someone's simple doesn't mean
that's stupid yeah i think it is it's
like
a simple person is not really i haven't
really got much going
for them anyway so electric yeah
definitely definitely the way to go yes
uh you'll test it the problem is if i
end up having to go electric what car
would i possibly get
i'd have to get the big tesla uh the
thing is the big tesla
honestly verb i just don't think they
look i don't think you'd love it
do not i really don't but it opened the
door you look yeah
but it looks like a wings it looks like
a van
for starters it's just not cool it's
like a spaceship
yeah spaceship van same thing it looks
like a mum car
like question are you missing holidays
i am missing holidays so so much
but we're in lockdown we're in lockdown
and we've got a newborn which kind of
ties in well because a newborn stops you
traveling overseas yeah we normally
travel like two or three times a year
yeah
and we go and learn as well go alone
leave the kids at home yeah
um not on their own deliver your parents
go away for a week or two three times a
year somewhere really exotic somewhere
beautiful
um in fact we'll have to talk about the
best places to go real quick in a minute
as well
and um we haven't been away but because
you've been pregnant and then we've got
a baby
and locked down yeah it's kind of like
combination imagine if we just as we
left a lot down
you became pregnant that would suck
two years of no travel yeah that would
suck but i think
if things go to plan so i think we're
allowed to travel from may the 17th
yeah but i think towards the end of the
year we usually do a december holiday i
think
if that goes as you know well i know
because i've got an august holiday book
tour everywhere
for us yeah the miami one yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah i forgot about that you forgot
about that i've got a business meeting
so
again tax deductible right obviously you
have to be careful and run everything
past your account but if you're
you can tie in a business meeting with a
holiday
yeah kill two birds well you're there
anyway everything every if you can claim
things back
obviously not of course the the entire
holiday but but the flights and stuff
like that
and be smart we're meeting the grant
cardone i'm excited
and if you haven't met grant cardone
anymore i haven't no
i haven't um and i'm a big fan as well
so i think i'd be so nervous
but what about the time you met kevin
hart okay
okay samuel i love kevin hart a comedian
he's american
and samuel surprised me with tickets to
go see him
vip front row and also to meet him after
and i literally thought me and kevin i
was like oh
i was like he if he knew me we'd
actually be friends because i just feel
like we have the same humor
when i met him i was just like
hi hi kevin never seen anyone so
starstruck
how long will we check again for five
ten minutes yeah not long short short
time
it was really short but the whole time
it was just amanda i was
shocked how amazing he is yeah how funny
he is but i was so nervous he was really
nice he was so nice
you had this strange voice that i've
never heard before he always says this
but i don't
it was like a posh voice he was like you
suddenly lost your northern twang
like um this is like hello kevin it's so
good to meet you
who's this who's this girl what what i
was making a good impression
yeah but he was nice he was really nice
it was so cool meeting him like
he's just amazing i love kevin hart i
don't think i'd heard of kevin hart
until we got married
no no i've never heard of him just like
you haven't heard of some really famous
people
like who like mika yeah i hadn't heard
of me
i told you to see me took me to see mika
and i was just like wow he's literally
same level as beyonce
he is just an incredible same level in
terms of talent in terms of
definitely not fans no no no not fame
not fame he should be as well known
because
what was he going to see the good thing
about going to see people like mika is
he's really talented i love mika
yeah but he's not that famous true so it
was quite intimate when
like beyonce oh my goodness we got good
seats there
and it was just the the the chance of
going to chat with beyonce after the
show
even if you get the best best best suit
it just isn't happening
um you just can't but whereas whereas
with the smaller like we saw we saw mika
coming over
anything but we were very close up all
right beyonce
she was we got really good which was so
far away yeah it just it was just awful
yeah all right best places to travel
where do you want to go so we're going
to go to miami oh yeah i've been to
miami
miami
is amazing um i can't wait to go tonight
i've been to a lot more places you've
been to
when we got married yeah i was jet set
all over the world and you were not
coming with me
how weird is that because now i'd bring
you i know yeah it's with that why did
you always stay at home
i'm not sure i don't know but i remember
when when i had ruby you were traveling
a lot so she was obviously a baby baby
so
i was going to south africa florida yeah
so that just didn't
fly but before that i'm i'm not sure why
i didn't come maybe i was going for like
a businessy thing
it was business you did travel a lot biz
for business stuff yeah
i remember remember when you asked me to
come to poland i think was it poland
i think i think it was poland and then i
was kind of just thinking
oh i don't really know and she said no
because you didn't want to go to poland
so i went on my own
yeah and then about six months later she
went to poland yeah i have been to
poland now
at the time i think it's just because i
thought when you're doing your thing
yeah like
it's sucky for you yeah just going
around with myself is boring yeah if i'm
going if i'm like speaking and i've got
meetings
yeah going for me she might just be
thinking nah
whereas your girl's trip was a bit a
little bit different yeah but um
okay so best places we've been um
california was incredible yes
that's amazing a month in california
yeah we we literally went to
we went all down the coast so we went
from san diego all the way up to san
francisco i think they're opposite ends
that's best best thing to say in
california best place to go best hotel
oh the beverly hills hotel that was nice
oh
worst hotel in california the cecil the
center
it's in downtown l.a but they've
actually just recently put
put a documentary about it on netflix
how it looks nice
it looks nice and the lobby looks like
pleasant it's all right okay
it's infamous for murders disappearances
suicides just horrible darkness
however we went to the settle and it
looks nice when you first walk inside
yeah it's quite cheap
i don't know why we stayed there i don't
know i think we spent so
much money we did on that trip we we
budgeted 20 grand and we spent 66 grand
yeah and we tend to do that don't we i
know it's just
experiences yeah yeah and then towards
the end of the month i was just like
honey honey we can't be staying in these
three grand a night hotels
let's just go downtown la and just book
somewhere normal and just enjoy
normal life to see what a normal person
and we booked
he was like i think it was like 50 60
pounds really cheap it looks quite
decent when you get it
okay yeah it looks all right but then we
were in there we were in the bedroom
and we were watching this thing on
youtube about this lady
this chinese lady called eliza lam yeah
who went dis who went just disappeared
she went to california she disappeared
mr she turned that she died and the real
mystery of how she died
this horrible documentary watching it
and the name of the hotel
was this sissel hotel the one we were
in it was like 11 p.m
and amanda's like we need to leave i
hated it because i didn't really have
good vibes
anyway but then when you watch that and
it was just literally coincidence that
you just happened to watch that
and it was the hotel that we were in and
it was just so
spooky and i was just thinking i don't
want to sleep here you know when you
don't sleep well it was one of those
where you just like
can't wait but we decided to because we
feared more
leaving yeah at night yeah because it's
in a really horrible area
like really near skid row
we didn't realize this as well because i
thought downtown downtown l.a
cool bear in mind the night before we
were at the beverly hills hotel yeah
and we've been to all these fancy nice
yeah where did we stay when we went to
las vegas
that was like just after this successful
experience remember
but las vegas was amazing las vegas is
just i want to go back there one day
we don't really drink much amazing we
don't really drink much
although you did that when we were in
las vegas yeah she actually
i had one drink and it knocked me out i
knew that would happen though because
you knocked me
what did you drink it was vodka and cook
but they literally put too much vodka in
it
i saw i saw them do it right so she she
went i love a vodka and coke
and i don't really ever exactly yeah i
don't drink i i have a bit of beer or
whatever but i don't we neither of us
are big drinkers at all
um we don't go out we don't get drunk
yeah i've never i've never done that
so there she goes oh come on i have a
vodka and coke i see him put the vodka
in i'm thinking
that's a lot of vodka she drinks it and
she's like kind of like necks it yeah
i'm like whoa and then she's fine and
then like two minutes later she's like
honestly it's the the room started
spinning and i was just like well first
you have the little her
giggly face yeah
oh my gosh she threw up i threw it all
down the bowling alley
uh i think i think you managed to get a
lot of it in the bin yeah
it was just awful i've never i've never
been that girl don't want to be that
girl but
that girl how did i react did i find it
funny or was i i can't know
you were quite helpful yeah you were
nice too i think i was worried i was
like
yeah what was going on um but apart from
that we didn't drink on that holiday at
all yeah i know he didn't
that's what happens when you don't drink
and then you do drink yeah it's too much
well yeah las vegas is great yeah we
didn't spend a penny on gambling
no he didn't did it we never went into
the casino we didn't even
like what the slot machines we didn't do
anything i remember that place you know
it feels like it's
daytime but it's just nighttime yeah
yeah
it was just it was like nothing i've
never seen anything like this
yeah i was going to say dubai is another
place that we loved we enjoyed
stayed at the birds
oh man so again samuel loves experiences
i'm not that bothered but we had this
like a sweet i say it was a sweet it
literally was like
you could go upstairs in it we had a
butler it was just
insane that was good it was insane it
was like an apartment
oh it was amazing if you ever get a
chance to go to the burj al-arab
yeah it was nice amazing
um place where the place went to in asia
have been great singapore what's it
called
mandalay what was it called the mandalay
bay hotel something like that man the
one with the three it's like iconic oh
man
that was amazing all over thailand some
of the best
in that little like villa place that you
found right let's end this podcast and
book some flights to go to
okie dokie yes i'm sold i'm sorry
honestly i
i do mean i am missing holidays what
we've tried to do during lockdown
is we tried to turn our house into like
a holiday vibe we've got like a bit of a
beachy looking house yeah the weather's
been good
we've got um instead of spending them on
holidays we spent the money on a swift
bar yep
so we've got a beautiful swimming pool
every penny oh my gosh
we said that will either be the best or
worst investment yeah
um so good how much for the 30 000 i
think it was 30 000 pounds
uh shout out to what's the name of the
company christina at hot
swim spa yeah i think we should leave a
link in the description
if anyone wants a it took a while to
come
um but when it came it was worth it yeah
and we've had that now for
quite what would you say probably come
on
yeah about nine months um it's big you
can swim in it but it's like it's
also going to swim there yeah it's like
a treadmill for swimming
it can actually work out in it yeah and
uh jacuzzi's
best thing that's so nice you can change
the temperature so when it's hot
it's cooler and that sounds stupid but
having palm trees in your garden
kind of makes it feel like you're like
that was what's sold
in the house with a hot tub with palm
trees
nice weather we watched the stars yeah
it is amazing so we've kind of
tried to turn our house into a holiday
sort of vibe and it does feel like every
day is a holiday it does especially when
you're with
the most amazing person ever um
but yeah i look forward to miami i'm
looking forward to that too so more of
the story
i can't remember what we were electric
cars yep tax deductible holidays yeah
if you can guilty birds enjoy
experiences that's certainly what i do
rather than things things don't make you
happy you know but experiences
experiences that's true unless it's a
good bag see i love
designer bags so you know for me that's
like her
she tries to convince joy enjoy joy
tries to convince me
that it's an investment it is it is it
is
right because the louis vuitton that you
got me once for my birthday
yeah that is now more expensive than
when you bought it for me
by like maybe 200 pounds so it has gone
up in value so yes
bags are an investment do you mean the
do you mean your bag has gone up in
barrier or
or that bag if it was that bag if it was
brand new however if i was gonna sell it
in really good condition it would still
hold its value quite well
i could probably sell it for how much
you bought it for as they're now more
expensive in the shop okay
okay i'm just saying okay um as this
is an investment channel i just can't
have you say that
i just can't let that go it's true
it's true you can buy bags and then
resell them but do you not think you're
better off
to just accept like my car yeah i could
try and convince myself it's a good
return
i could say to you because it massages
whenever it saves
me booking massages and because this one
just isn't okay because it's
it's um i don't know how can i convince
that it's a good return on investment
um i might be able to get a deal when
i'm doing a property because they might
see my content oh that's nice
and it's gonna do but like or i can say
oh you know
it's comfy so i'm more likely to say yes
to go on a long
journey business trip because i've got a
comfy car like i could try and convince
myself somehow and justify
that it's a good commercial decision to
own the car or i can just go
it's actually a terrible commercial
decision you know what
i love it and it's a treat and i want it
no problem i can afford it
like do you not think that maybe better
off just accepting that the louis
vuitton bags and the gucci bags
are a terrible investment would you like
them i don't think they're a terrible
investment what do you think
let us know in the comments yeah also if
you've got questions
for me or for amanda yeah about anything
lifestyle
or anything at all comment below yeah
and we will answer
pretty much anything yep in next week's
podcast
also we need a name for the podcast yes
we do so let us know
in the comments what do you think the
podcast should be called and
hopefully if i can convince amanda i'm
really surprised
what the jessica has not woken up to
english i know yeah because it was a bit
we've not had any disturbances from no
ruby from luke from jessica
they were playing quietly or sleeping
what a miracle
what a miracle so let us know what
should the podcast be called comment
below
final words of wisdom i don't really
have any but
have a great week and thank you for
watching we love you guys
[Music]
you